la loi immigration est enfin votée dans
une version durcie par rapport à celle
proposée par le gouvernement à l'origine
on vous fait le résumé tout commence le
11 décembre une motion de rejet proposé
par les écologistes est adopté à
l'Assemblée nationale par les groupes
d'opposition dont LR et le rassemblement
national le projet de loi immigration
n'est donc pas débattu par les députés
le 18 décembre le texte passe alors
devant une commission mixte paritaire où
SEP députés et SEP sénateurs choisis
proportionnellement à leur poids
politique se réunissent à H clos pour
aboutir à l'écriture d'un texte commun
celle-ci est majoritairement composée de
C parlementairire macroniste cinq de
droite puis trois de gauche et un du RN
mais la Réunion est suspendue deux fois
en raison de désaccord entre la droite
et les macronistes au bout de 24 heures
de discussion un accord est finalement
trouvé ce mardi après-midi le texte est
durci réforme de l'aide médicale d'État
rétablissement du délit de séjour
irrégulier assouplissement des
conditions d'expulsion ou encore
restriction du droit du sol la droite
impose ses fondamentaux la gauche
nupesse dénonce ce texte quand Marine Le
Pen annonce que son parti le RN le
votera le texte doit ensuite être soumis
au Sénat puis à l'Assemblée nationale
pour pour être définitivement adopté à
20h13 sans surprise car dominé par la
droite le Sénat adopte le texte de loi
par 214 voix pour et 114 contes mais
tout doit se jouer à l'Assemblée
nationale où l'adoption est loin d'être
faite l'aile gauche de la majorité
macroniste étant défavorable au
durcissement du texte à 21h30 les débats
débutent à l'Assemblée nationale où ils
sont plus mouvementés et tendus qu'au
Sénat une motion de rejet déposée par la
France assousmise est largement rejeté
par l'émicycle alors que la même France
assoumise voit un point de bascule dans
le projet le RN et LR ne cach pas leur
satisfaction à 23h22 on procède enfin au
vote le projet de loi est largement
adopté par 349 voix pour et 186 voix
contre donc grâce au voix des
républicains et du RN en parvenant à
sceller un accord sur des mesures
durcies la droite a réussi à rester uni
et ferme pour la première fois depuis le
début du quinquena au gouvernement les
tensions et les divisions risquent en
revanche de laisser des
traces